councelor SOA you're not an
apology sorry she appears to be here
yeah yeah okay right welcome everyone to
the December 5 infrastructure Services
meeting uh apologies we just need to
correct I've got councel Bo but lesle
and councel cracket okay sorry councilor
so down apologies for that apology for
the
apology not till tomorrow tomorrow okay
sorry it's ended up on here okay can I
have someone move that we accept those
apologies move Grant second did Ria put
that all those in favor
I okay that now moves on to we have no
Zoom attendees there's no public
forum uh we have a major late item which
is a verbal update on recycling
future um I'll move that can I have
someone second there please second all
those in
favor thank you uh we also have a minor
a item uh regarding recycling but was
presented to me late and I'm not
allowing that to go ahead today it's
going to come back at another
infrastructure
meeting so now we move on to the minutes
of the waste Advisory Group uh that were
on the 16th of October um Barry you were
there you like to move those turn
correct thank you second uh uh Peter you
were there okay put that motion all
those in
favor that's carried that takes us to
the minutes of the infrastructure commit
Comm meeting 7th of
November someone mov thank you paa
seconded Barry put those true and
correct all those in favor I against
there is Carri takes us now to the
CCTV policy deliberations now who would
Ranna do you want us
no I'm afraid ran is unwell so you got
me thanks but I promise I know at least
something about what I'm talking about
so aoto good afternoon counselors um
hopefully this will be quite brief um so
CCTV uh draft policy as you know um was
consulted on alongside the city block uh
hearings um as the report details there
weren't a lot of submissions directly on
CCTV um so we haven't made too many
changes the submissions that we did
receive we thought were really helpful
so we went ahead and Incorporated them
um but they are pretty minor so um to go
over those we've um put a long stop date
of 90 days for storage of um footage um
unless otherwise otherwise specified but
the intention is that each camera's um
specific storage uh period will have to
be specified um but that's only going to
be known as the roll that happens um but
this long stop is sort of a um sort of a
catchall date so no footage is going to
be accidentally kept longer than needed
um the exception to that of course
forces if it's identified as needed for
criminal proceedings um in which case um
an exception can be made um and again
these amendments um arose from the
submissions um but also and they're in
line with the um guidelines from the
Privacy
commissioner um we've also added in a
few extra words just to strengthen um
the requirements around for example the
use of footage um access to recorded
footage uh so again some more details
there about the types of um preventative
measures we might take to make sure that
it's kept secure um and then a few more
details on how uh people can make
complaints um should the need arise um
otherwise um there's very little so the
policy has been laid out in um a new
format which is the um the version that
you'll have been given with the yellow
highlights um and I'd like to say a
special thank you to our comm's team
who've done a beautiful job of creating
this template for us which we're hoping
to use going forwards make it look a bit
more shiny and hopefully people will
read it um but otherwise that's about it
unless anyone has any questions I'd be
very happy to right questions
Tom I very much support the 90-day
longstop date can I just ask whether
that requires some human intervention
after 90 days or is there an automatic
deletion um I don't know that at this
point um and I'm sure that will become
known as the um details of the new
system put into place so this policy has
been circulated around at least some of
the project team um so they're going to
be aware of that and and that I said
much of this is going to be known as
those details um as we get to that point
in the project I mean ask that question
because I understand you know you not a
position you answered it but I think for
those who are going to be involved um I
would very much support it being
automatic because if it requires human
intervention it will not necessarily
harm
TR through you Mr cheer currently it's
autom de and so what we do is we tag
data if we need to retain it for longer
than 90 days so or 30 days so this would
it's quite common in most systems but we
hear that and we can take that on board
operationally okay good Tom uh Novi just
clarifications um one is it it states
never to use the footage except with the
intended purpose that's a very general
statement
very general statement so where's the
intended purpose I mean is it just
something broad like Community
safety and what
Pandora box does that open up when you
start having AAS yeah so what what the M
raised is a interesting question like
the use and I know one city in New
Zealand that uses it to monitor the bus
lane that you're not supposed to go in
and then send out infringement notices
now I don't think we intend to use it
for traffic offenses um I don't think
that's the thing but that I think that's
what the me is asking about its actual
use yeah so through you again um the
purpose for each camera is to be
identified with that camera as it's
installed um when we drafted the policy
we um added in um a list of sort of um
general purposes that are allowed that
we are allowing um the CCTV to be put in
place for and yes again I I acknowledge
that it is quite broad but that's sort
of necessary at a policy level um
because the specific purposes will be
known as those cameras are are installed
um so that detail will be will be added
and that's again where we've put in um
the need for various procedures and
documentation um that will be
developed yeah just some supplementary
questions to that so just to use an
example if we're not going to have a
generic statement like for Community
safety and we're going to do what the
policy suggests which is each camera we
install will have its own criteria
that's an absolute mindfield so I just
want to signal that and the other issue
is um what happens like we we manage the
liquor Licensing Laws so what happens if
I'm a policeman looking or um looking at
a I don't know an assault going on down
in D3 and I see somebody stagger out of
one of the local
licensing areas absolutely drunk beyond
belief would I yeah going to Bo his hand
up but is that a legal use of a camera
to say hey to ask a question of the
lense e hey was he being served on your
premises so I can answer that no they
can't because you would need to prove
which you couldn't that they were
intoxicated there was a case previously
where uh we tried to Pang a local um
business for serving someone who was
intoxicated based on the method of
walking where in fact that person had a
disability yeah they were drunk they
were and just a final question chair um
is around the 90-day provision so I just
want to be clear that we will hold it
for 90 days unless the police come back
and ask otherwise and given the staty
limit for murder is open-ended it could
be 20 30 40 50
years if they ask then we hold it till
they say they don't need it any longer
is that the idea I'm not sure you have
to ask Tre
through you Mr chair it it really
depends on the circumstances if we've
received a warrant for data for example
and that warrant stipulates it we're
going to hand over that evidence as
we're required to by law uh we we will
hold an incident until it has been
through the court if it relates to um
our body cam for example with staff at
the moment but uh every circumstance is
different but usually for something like
that for a murder you're going to need a
warrant and there'll be or there could
be footage that may we may not have or
that a cold case from 20 you know that
happens today that they're investigating
in 20 years we wouldn't have the data
for that is just the nature of the Beast
I don't know if that answered the
question
sir yeah I'm not I'm not sure um because
you know if we've got serious crimes
that have a an unlimited um data being
dealt with by the police are they going
to be in here all the time sort of
saying yep we had an assault in there
we're not sure who the person is we want
you to keep all your all your cameras
and I won't just be the one cameras
focused at the area because they'll have
a right to ask for other adjoining
cameras and this is the coming back to
the camera by camera stuff again um is
that you can't just say well look I'm
sorry the guy was seen running down the
road and as he gets around the corner he
comes on to another camera we can't give
you that because that's not what the
camera set up for so I just want us to
be quite clear about what we're managing
going
forward you look like you've moved
into I didn't like talking to the pillar
yeah I've been call many
things I I believe that the policy gives
us the ability to record data for what
its intended purposes for for cameras
that have been aligned to being for
security and safety of city streets that
that data will be recorded on a camera
that allows that it'll be recorded and
stored for up to 90 days unless we have
uh a warrant or there's an incident
where we know that we have to tag that
data and keep it aside that's my
understanding does that help yep and so
just to help me understand the original
issue which is the camera by camera
designation like you know if we're
putting I don't know what we're putting
50 or 60 cameras in the CBD in what
circumstances would those cameras have
different criteria on them only if that
was something to do with the CCTV
project as a hole if it had outline that
there were a series of cameras for
example that were only to monitor
vehicle traffic numbers on a street and
I've made that up that's not what Erin's
doing but if there was something
specific like that that camera can only
collect that data for
that yeah just bear with me as I tease
one more step so if we have some of it
that's not General Security of the
community and other areas that we have
just traffic management then when
somebody's run over by a car in the
traffic Management Area the police can't
use it potentially that's correct but
I'm not aware that we have that at the
moment so we rather we have a gap of no
camera whatso so there is no data but
the camera that I understand what we're
putting in for are for security for the
community and safety for the community
and so those cameras are the top that
what will you'll be tracking the data on
some cameras if they are a specific type
of camera such as tracking um traffic
numbers they're set up so they don't
record specific vehicles or people they
only tag a number so they're no good to
someone to look at as such they're just
recording data in a
space
um if I could just add to that as well
um specifically for the police um they
the policy envisages that police will be
asked to fill out a request form for
footage um for a specific incident they
would have to specify exactly what
they're looking for which cameras they
wanted to look at and then we can
respond to that and that's something
similar to what we do at the moment um
but um we planning to have more robust
documentation around it so the police
can say we believe that a an incident
happened in this location do you have
any camera footage and they can ask for
that if we don't have it for whatever
reason we don't have it um if we do have
it and they have grounds to request it
and and again as treat is indicated if
they had a warrant or something like
that then we could hand it over um but
again they'll have to fill out a form
they go through a process and it's
planned that we enter into um some kind
of memorandum of understanding with the
police um or similar uh which sets out
the um the rules um which would govern
that just to interrupt there sorry um
you've touched on an issue that the
police have to apply 1:00 in the morning
in the control room something's
happening they need to rewind go back
access some stuff how do they do
that so again that's what the um the aim
of a memorandum of understanding with
the police would be and again that's
going to be something that we'll have to
work out um depending on the technology
and depending on the type of access the
police have um but um from doing
research around New Zealand some
councils do have um an ability for
police to just show up and access
footage at any time some of them require
a longer process um so that will depend
on the types of cameras that we have and
and how they're used and what agreement
we enter into with police so just follow
on that because I'm still not clear
maybe I'm just having a bad day
um if we're going to do camera by camera
by camera identification of what the
purpose of the camera is and if it's not
for Community safety then why the hell
are we putting it in the first place
place our job is not to do traffic
management but given that that's an
example of how it might go away from
general safety I'm not sure how the
police would get to it if for say we had
some Hoon driving through the areas
where the cameras are looking at the um
looking at the traffic management and
they see somebody run over or a car
smash into another car whatever it be
because this says under no circumstances
will count authorize the use of a
footage outside its
designation but at that point aren't
they committing a crime who those people
not it may not be I mean I Ed it a bad
example but you know if people are
hooning around or whatever you know
police might want to get on top of that
before they end up with a crime L
attraction is crime I think this um just
want to say that this is the draft
policy and this will come this will move
on the 19th to council won it this to be
adopted the policy was to be adopted by
this committee unless no in that case
I'm completely wrong it's to be
recommended to council correct Okay so
we've got two weeks to do some fine
tuning and I think those questions if
they are things like that in detail like
the M raising we've got that time I
think in the middle too y yep um I think
what I'd encourage us is to remember
that the CCTV policy isn't specific to
the CCTV project that we currently have
underway that CCTV project um we need to
make sure that we absolutely get the
scoping right around that and that we're
very clear on what we want um those
cameras to provide in terms of a a
balance between Community need and cost
obviously it might be nice for cameras
to do everything but we want to be very
practical around what that need is and
keep the scope limited um to something
that is Affordable to the community um
but to the point that was made around we
we already have CCTV that is in place at
the moment outside of that project and
this policy also relates to that
existing
CCTV but absolutely we'll take on board
that feedback as it relates to the
project and if I could add a final point
it was um sort of envisaged in the
report that um we we anticipate that
issues may arise as part of the
implementation as part of the roll out
and um if if anything arises we will
bring it back to council for
consideration if any changes needed to
be made um at this point we are trying
to put something in place that's
comprehensive um that gets us a starting
point so that we can get the project um
that next step um
along okay um move on to Grant yeah
thanks to you so
um this isn't the first CCT project in a
city what what um other policies have we
reviewed from other towns or cities I
don't have a full list off the top of my
head but it was a lot I did a pretty
comprehensive review of um as many uh
published CCTV policies as I could find
some councils um just just incorporate
it as part of their privacy policy some
councils have a standalone CCTV policy
um obviously we've decided now to break
the CCTV section out of the privacy
policy um which is where it used to be
contained um but yes I reviewed it
against as many as I could find um and
found the sort of most consistent
approaches and then what would work for
this Council specifically yeah okay um
and then probably a little bit to
um the question I note in the policy
you've got review 20 29 mhm um maybe
that should be a little bit shorter
given it's a new policy should be a
review in the first year yep and then
can roll out to perhaps a longer
sequence post post that would be just a
thought you know because it is a a new
policy and I think 's point is also a
good point where we've got existing um
cameras but equally we've got some new
cameras coming in and they may be
different so there might be a subset to
it so that'll reflect through on the
policy that KS received in couple weeks
yeah no and and thank you it's a it's a
good point um six years is just our
standard review period so absolutely
there's a good reason to bring that
forward thank you thank you Che right
takes us on Darren you still want to go
no okay
Evelyn um so my question sort of been
answered in part
but given that one of the conversations
the biggest part has been about
Community safety and improving
um how people feel in terms of safety
within their Community um including
protection of assets and all those sorts
of things um I would like to
know for my clarification are we able to
be proactive
about um keeping or t tagging
information to be kept even though at
the within the 90 days there hasn't been
an official request from police for a
crime because for the very reasons that
have been said sometimes there's a gap
between an event and the police becoming
um looking at further um proceedings so
one do Council staff have the right to
see that an event has taken place in tag
it um for longer duration than 90 days
or does it always have to be police that
initiate the 90 days so in other words
can we on behalf of the citizens make a
a proactive decision to say this may be
needed for a prosecution further down
the road including Council Prosecuting
somebody if it's an offense against
Council property for
example for you Mr chair so I just want
to keep us back we're doing the policy
today in terms of the operations of CCTV
cameras we have operational guidelines
that occur today within Council um and
we tag footage where we have uh meet
some prerequisites for staff but I won't
go into that in detail no so um longer
term we can always review those
operational policies um and balance out
uh we can't keep it all for 90 for um 90
years uh but it's it's usually it's
pretty obvious what we need to keep if
that makes
sense right yeah no so I recognize the
operational sensitivities what I was
really concerned about is that we might
preclude ourselves from doing that if
the wording of this is not permitting of
it given that the extent that Hannah has
gone to looking at different CCTV
policies there was nothing in there when
I saw it that made me think of that it
looked very similar to most Council type
or other organizations CCTV
policies um but it's about the operation
and training and procedures we put in
place following the policy that create
the benefit thank you I think the other
piece is because that next project is
such a large change we'll come back and
review the policy as we roll out that
project to make sure that everything
aligns and if there are any updates that
are required
thank you for that
clarification okay
Lesley thanks Mr chair um's partly said
what I was going to say but not entirely
um I just thought the purpose issue was
getting into a bit of a circular
discussion because page 21 has got the
cameras
multiple as in cameras plural with seven
bullet points for purposes and that
covers everything from the enhancing
Public Safety through to assisting other
agencies improving staff security etc
etc there's seven bullet points there
and it's cameras plural so at the moment
the policy is providing for all cameras
not just the one project and for a
series of seven very clear
purposes to me that's what the policy
needs to do at this point the
refinements will come later and on page
24 we have then got the storage
issue it says and will in all cases be
deleted within 90 days unless retained
for a specific purpose it actually
leaves open who might Define that
specific purpose it Le it has an example
of possible criminal criminal
proceedings but that's only an example
the specific purposes will also be
operationally further defined and to me
that's what a policy should be saying at
the moment
so rather than get any further into the
what might be refined further in
operational policies uh operational
procedures I think what we've got is a
good comprehensive policy that allows
the further
refinement and congratulations because I
can imagine it took quite some putting
together to get to this point yes it was
Ellen yeah I just on 21 as well I was
just sort of thinking that um when we
first started talking about cameras it
was all about public safety and it seems
to have now gone from public saf it's
still included in there of course but
it's come from Public Safety to actual
policing and of course if you start
using those cameras for say traffic
violation um that's what they being used
for do you not think people may look on
them um as not being a positive thing
possibly a negative thing and of course
if anybody pleads not guilty to anything
then you're going to have to keep the
footage for that possibly 90 days to
before they they get a court
date you know so do you not think you're
making a a work pray our own backs so as
I as I understand it counselor we can't
do that legally at the moment anyway
it's not set up you can't um as I
understand it Michael Mr Morris will
know but I didn't think we could do that
anyway that's right so we we haven't
specifically do you mean the bottom dot
point on page um managing traffic mon
traffic mov that doesn't say policing
it's just talking with reg
functions and for business Improvement I
mean I thought that's an unusual one at
the moment there's we by law we can't do
that that could that was floated as a
change by central government at one
point like I mean I can see a use of it
in TR traffic management you look with
the new Street layouts we've got Dawn
and Es and you get a queue of cars
waiting at the lights and you know staff
can't be there looking at it all the
time and of course it only lets two cars
through that's not good enough so we
need traffic management things like that
are totally acceptable and you know
being aware of that it's a bit it is
completely different to policing and I'm
quite happy with the wording of that
last bullet
point
yeah um so Tom
next thanks for giving me a second go
chair um I not withstanding what Leslie
said which I agree with about you know
the matters to be settled later but I I
think one of the fundamental things that
the public have got a right to expect
counselors to be able to articulate is
in what circumstances will CCTV footage
be released to particularly the police I
think we ought to be able to articulate
that at the moment in page 25 it might
be expressed differently elsewhere but
um what it says in page 25 is that if
police or other agencies wish to access
recorded CCTV footage they're required
to complete the CCTV footage request
form which sounds like a pretty low
bar you know you just go a complete a
form and I I I mean I think we did okay
I know I know there will be all sorts of
things will develop from this in terms
of operating standards but you know a
question I would expect to get is in
what circumstances can you release that
video and it would be I think a poor
response if I was to give the response
well the police have to fill in a form
that's you know there's going to be
criteria that are clearer than that I
think and even at an early
stage three Mr sh quite um and and I
agree um that that form um is yet to be
drafted um but absolutely take your
point that it's not as simple as filling
out a form and automatic um rights there
will be criteria to meet certainly um
but in in the next few weeks if if um
Council wishes we can definitely add in
some of that detail or um take that away
on advisement but I I perfectly take
your point um but not envisage that it
would be as low a bar as fill out a form
and automatic
rights okay
um Darren I'm going to let you go since
you since I I stood down earlier thanks
um the last slot actually monitored from
the watch house at the police
station um and I haven't heard that that
wouldn't be the case this time and I
think councilors also need to remember
that when the police came and asked for
it that they wanted license plate
recognition in there as well which
allows things like stallin vehicles or
vehicles of Interest I don't know that's
their definition not ours um to be
tracked as as they move about the city
so I have no problem with somebody
accessing the information if it's to
assist with the investigation of a crime
or to keep people
safe for anything else you know let's
say there's some fendering husband or
something that's that's not a crime it's
just something that's
stupid um and and even for um uh
monitoring traffic movements that that
that can help but also it can draw
attention to areas where there are
traffic snow ups that are going on
so when you take into account the amount
of time that you are surveying
elsewhere and for those of you who've
been in London or China um it's pretty
much all the time um at least you've got
something to hide I'm not sure what the
problem
is uh the Mia will make yours the last
one see Tom had two bites of the Cherry
um I guess there's two issues one is
that we we talk about having access to
stored uh footage but the police will
have live
active access all the time aren't they
so I mean that's so really all we're
dealing with in that scenario is what we
subsequently store yeah where they can
come back to it that's supp having life
the other issue is that in in this
debate there are two very big polarized
groups from what I see those that want
to be safe as they're out and about and
those who do not want Big Brother
looking over their shoulder all the time
and so for me it's important that we get
this right because while we say we can
amend it as we go along we all get legal
challenges the moment we step outside
and own rules for one of those two
groups either
way just never mind as you say but
satellite surveillance these days big
brother is literally yes I know above us
every time you carry a cell phone so
with that access I think that I think
this policy could potentially shape our
tendering process
because in the in the in the world of
supplying the correct software to use um
not all software allows a log
a permanent log if you go in an access
so that is that could become one of the
requirements that you can't you know it
actually you can't get in there without
you being labeled and it's permanent so
as well as the request forms and stuff I
think that ex extra level of security
could come through the tender process
maybe so we've got five recommendations
here can I have someone move those
thanks Darren and leely you're going to
put those recommendations all those uh
in favor I I against carried right the
next item I've been informed are going
to have to to keep that on the table or
um yes uh this is uh this item has got a
significant amount of History to it and
I um would recommend that Council will
want to hear from the staff who have
that information unfortunately both
Caroline rain and Russell Pearson are
unwell and are not um in the office
today so I would recommend we defer that
one until the next infrastructure
committee meeting
okay
right yep it's been withdrawn right
takes
us to the road stopping at Green Hills
now we do we need Russell for this no
Heather will be speaking thanks Heather
thank you Mr chair um
so this um road stopping
application was brought before Council
um to approve the process of the initial
consultation process through the
consultation process um we received a um
an objection from one of the occupiers
nearby um and um Council decision is to
either uphold the
um the opposition to the um road
stopping process and therefore stop the
road stopping process at this point or
to um to take the meta through to the
environment court for a hearing through
the environment court if they decide
that the opposition is not significantly
justifiable
right I'm not uh I'm actually I'm a bit
be willed by this um no oh actually
Darren I'm going to go straight to
Darren
so as a matter of process I have no
problem with moving the recommendations
there is the right of the object eor to
Lodge an
objection if if their objection went
through a process I'm sure that there
would be a method of mitigating any
concerns
so um it's been before us
um I I don't see that um
removing uh the road
classification would uh prevent
subdivision for the
objective
in that in that case you wouldn't be
moving the current recommendation
correct because the second
recommendation would say
sorry sorry you're quite right um I must
read time for a new prescription already
um I don't see
that if the objector wanted to Lodge an
application for
subdivision that something couldn't be
facilitated from with on with whatever
lots that had that they wanted to
subdivide this does provide the obor
with legal access to his property so
keeping the road as as it is and finding
an alternative way of um providing the
current occupier so to speak who's a
farmer um by an occupation agreement
until such time as the road is formed is
is a satisfactory way of retaining that
unformed legal road so we we uphold uh
two yeah yeah I'm going to go le
le thanks Mr chair I was going to say I
would be prepared to move both the
recommendations as they stand at this
time I would not think it was the
council's benefit to end up up in an
expensive environment court process
potentially um by taking the opposite
decision or
no particular discernable benefit I can
see the council at the moment there
there is no um cost to council by
retaining the the road as it is that's
what I'm meaning correct yes but there
would be a cost if we took the opposite
and in the environment court and
therefore I can't see why we
would potentially put ourselves in the
environment Court when the the other
position is demonstrated by the
recomendations as they
stand would give us a reasonable way of
continuing right um thank you liy uh
Kane liy so tached on my first one was
around you Zer cost for us to maintain
that but my other one is is there any
atttention to actually put a road
there into in the
future that is an answer I do not have
at this point um it would also depend on
whether there is any subdivision process
or whether there is access required from
that legal unformed Road
okay sorry Mrs C just can I just clarify
were you asking about was there any
intention from Council to put a road
there um to which Heathers um liased
with the infrastructure managers around
any use for that land to which they've
said no no sorry thank you Mr Mayor um
want to clarify this is just basically
paper rate isn't it currently used by
the farmer so that doesn't incur any
cost for anybody but it leaves the door
open for sub Vision in the future that
is correct well I'd support we retain
that position which is our
recommendation too right so Leslie has
moved uh recommendations one and two can
I have a second there please yep um Tom
I'm going to put those um two
recommendations all those in favor I I
against that is carried thank you thank
you takes us to Temporary uh road
closure uh of EST Street for white
Tangi is fist today Mr chair thank you
uh this application is for the Tempe
road closure of es Street for the Wang
Days festival it's uh they'll be putting
on music and uh cultural events and food
uh in terms of on the network it would
be very minor given what that 6 Street
now looks like it's not a through route
so um we don't have any objection to it
subject to an event management plan
being
submitted right I think this is what we
intended Easter Street to be used for so
I'll open up for
questions any questions yes Al just a
comment I'm just pleased to see using
stre instead of Street for a
change okay any question can we please
note my exstension okay and you're
welcome right so um no further questions
so uh we have one two three
recommendations uh moved Barry seconded
Peter I'm going to put that all those in
favor I as Carri thank you you
Mr Right got an intersection safety
report for the corner of y Street and
vanan uh thank you Mr chair I'm joined
by my colleague Grant fiser um this
report is an information report for uh
the committee regarding the intersection
of Euro and lindus farm basically what's
triggered this is um a crash history of
The Last 5 Years there's been 18 crashes
all of a similar kind currently it's um
currently it's uh priority priority
control as opposed to any any FMA
controls on that so what we're
recommending at this stage is uh a
traffic signal layout uh there are some
uh loss of parking in some areas some of
the legs uh but the consistent um
Behavior we're seeing and the Crash
records we're seeing is that traffic
from linders fan are failing to see
failing to giveway and hitting um being
being struck by cars on y Street and
because it's a lowp speed environment
essentially a 50k environment um we are
fortunate that the crashes are not more
serious so of the 18 crashes there's
been four minor crashes and one serious
one but there's also been a lot of
property damage as well with people
flying through um fences more than once
uh when we went to the consultation out
on the street as one of one of the
occupants told us they've rebuilt their
fence and wall a couple of times um so
we think this is a really good approach
um and we're certainly open for uh
comment and questions right I see the
recommendation is only to to Reed the
report so uh questions
Tom as a busy section is which I use
regularly is you know traffic lights
hold up traffic more than a roundabout
does is there no room for a roundabout
uh essentially no uh physically to do to
reduce the the crash type we would have
to have a larger diameter to do that
which would me property um purchase and
some and essentially into some buildings
as well so we' have to take buildings to
okay thank you Alan yeah just wondering
you got a little bit of retail area on
the corner there the northwest corner
are they all quite happy with that we um
both Grant and myself went out into a
site visit and knocked on the doors um
the response was overwhelmingly positive
however the Kebab shop on the corner the
manager was not there and I know that he
relies on that traffic so we're we're
open to uh amending where the parking is
without effective the design so we are
we are open to that and we've made that
offer as well um so we are talking to
them at the moment we've done a letter
drop as well to any other ref residents
but there was a sense of relief from a
lot of people when we went out
there Grant yeah just um cost and time
frame I'll pass you to Grant
here uh so cost will be delivered within
existing budgets um so it's co-funded
through W yes wak kahi um time frame
we're looking at uh delivery by end of
financial year uh next year so mid mid
2024 y
yeah okay and is the Walker K funding
already funding we've received or is it
part of the new but not already funding
we've received Y and the uh design
essentially delivers on um the a safe
system Solutions uh safe system solution
which is a requirement of the funding as
well and and that's under the 50/50
partnership with W um I believe so not
yeah the funding is 5050 that's correct
yeah thanks sure
Peter yeah thank you Mr chair the uh
question um the cost you said it's
within budget but could you give us a a
figure how much it will cost Council
to oh um I would need to come back to
the council sorry on the on the exact
figure
um Leslie thanks Mr chair as a frequent
user of Belinda's f yo
area I can understand the size of relief
that might have been head at um the
approach I certainly
um agree it would be good to consult on
this and bring it to a fruitful
conclusion that's that's been a problem
corner for a long time and it's well
known if you live in the in the area
that it has been a problem so it's good
to see the movement getting to the next
stage
and I'm happy to move it if no one else
has got other comments move to Leslie
second to
Darren oh P sorry you want to speak oh
no no right okay so we have mover in
second uh I'm going to put the
recommendation that we receive the
report all those in favor against that
is carried thank you guys sure thank
you moves us to item 11 the primary
infrastructure consenting
program
Alisa tall for me this
year H hi I'm Ellis
snow uh just working with Erin and
delivering the three consenting projects
purpose of the report is just to give
you an update uh on where it's at for
you to receive
it make sure you keep the mic close oh
say not close
enough uh so the three projects uh
involved in the this program uh the
bluff Wastewater um consent the Aur
alternative water supply and the clipton
Wastewater consent
project um we've commenced work uh on
two of them which is the bluff Waste
Water Treatment Plant and the
alternative water supply uh and Clifton
is scheduled to commence next year
Clifton's consent uh expires in 29 so
we've got sort of four and a half five
years to complete that work Bluff um the
end of
2025 and our is obviously a new consent
so that'll go through its own separate
process uh ar ar is at the moment um
Works progressing on on proving the
chattan
aquafer uh and work was is commencing
this month which is based around
developing a numerical model around what
the aquer can deliver retesting the
existing B holes and then looking at
putting into some new B holes to test
where we think a b field may be required
so all that work will continue over the
next four to 6 months hopefully July
next year we'll have have some results
to confirm the capability of the efer at
the current
location okay yep you still carry on
okay uh for Bluff um works also well on
the way there that we've got a project
team together they are working away um
there's two key there's three key
streams of work uh the first is around
um uh the BPO process which is a best
practical option process which we'll
need to run through be able to
demonstrate uh for the consent um and
we're just entering the first stage or
the option hearing for that which is
called the Fatal flaw stage so that's
commencing actually tomorrow uh and
that'll get us through the option heing
process to our best to our preferred
option which is scheduled for we should
know by July next
year uh the other the other one is a
business case so we've kept off the
business case so we can actually make
sure that we understand what are the
problems that we are trying to solve for
that project uh and also making sure
we're making the best decisions for
Council and the community and we
understand what the options actually
mean for the community so that process
is is also happening and also the third
stream is around consultation so we're
working with Tammy and the other key
stakeholders to um to make sure we get a
consultation going
early um yeah that's that's it there
probably the only other item is that for
Bluff I've identified in the report um
some key gateways which are suggesting
we bring information up to the
infrastructure group so you can make so
you understand where we are and we're
making the what decisions are being made
during the process so they're identified
in the report so there sort of six
gateways of identified
there right thank you for that I'm going
to open up questions Grant yeah thanks
CH just um with your gateways just
wonder if it's a if you could add to
that the um engagement plan around
stakeholders specifically relating to
the bluff Community with their waste
water yes um you know that it's really
important sit on the community board
down there and um you know it's
important we keep them informed and
engaged in the process so it be good to
see that stakehold engagement plan as
part of those
gateways yeah well that the first
draft's actually been completed so I can
submit that so that covers all the
consultation all the stakeholders yeah
and there is Bluff yeah but what I'm
meaning is the dedicated what the
ongoing commitment to engagement and
probably the better best example is what
um the aluminium smell to do they have
regular regular meetings which are
accessible by the community they have
one in Bluff they have one in town and
um they always get good turnouts
particularly down in Bluff and there's
some good engagement with the bluff
Community between the two entities and
so there's a good model there you can
I'm happy to speak to that one um at
this stage we are engaging through the
bluff community board rather than
directly with the community um it's not
the sort of project where we would um
take out I guess direct Community
engagement normally around a consent so
I think um I'd be interested in um if
Council think we need to engage other
than through the community board those
you know key stakeholders obviously T
marama the local runanga um Etc yeah no
so what I was meaning was was it'd be
great to be able to show the bluff
community board when you're going to
come to them and engage so what's the
program of Engagement with spef we've
actually invited the bluff community
board onto the governance group um
however at this stage they haven't um
been able to provide a resource to
attend that and have just asked us to
keep them informed through the community
board
meetings yeah be good to see a
structured approach to that so if it's
quarterly or it's six monthly and then
yeah I'm not aware but it may have
happen that if there's anyone else that
they think should be engaged no it's
okay I just wanted to clarify that we
weren't planning to do like a
consultation like we were doing the mall
or something like that how we going keep
them informed in the structure that's no
worries Tom
so this is really just for my
clarification I'm not challenging the
use of the word or anything but I I was
intrigued by Under The Bluff Wastewater
consent the the relationship with tarama
tamy is described as a partnership the
partnership with tarama what do you mean
by that um Partnerships discussed in the
charter of agreement between Council and
so we're just trying to keep that
relationship going um we're also trying
to approach it on a as a any partnership
is so it's a it's a two-way Arrangement
so we're keeping them a breast
of uh of what's happening during the
project as we progress through and
giving them the opportunity to give us
feedback regularly through that so they
are now joining the governance group as
well um and they've also made a
recommendation that the two key raka
also join the governance Group which
which we which we've agreed to as well
so what will the meop of the governance
group be then um key El members um
operational managers and uh uh and
tamy and the the Rau and um we've also
asked the the um community board to join
but as heon said earlier they
declined okay thank you Mr
Mayor probably most of these questions
are for um
um
for eron um so on the first page of the
report it talks about um Capital
placements so when you look at um
Clifton forag like 89 million is's a
majority that not upgrading the plant
but actually the the water to land
discharge it runs from the plant there's
a placeholder in there around we we
don't know what the solution will be at
this stage until work through that um So
based on I guess a range of different
solutions that we've seen around the
country there's essentially a middle
ground number in there depending on
where we get
to it could be more it could be less so
if if if through the current um
coalition government um we get some
relief from this and we uh could follow
other councils and water to water
discharge
so we continue what we're doing at the
moment is it fair to say that most of
the bluff and Clifton cost you got there
would
disappear I don't believe so um do or
don't believe sorry what was that you do
or don't I don't believe they would y um
and that's because we're already under
significant pressure from environment
Southland as the Wastewater regulator as
well as from a number of community
groups around the discharges um both
from our landfill and our wastewater
treatment plant into the EST um we do
believe that we will most likely have to
do something different there in the
future and that's the provision that
we've made okay um I mean I've had
feedback from government and you can see
it in the document here that we don't
know what's replacing three Waters and
we don't know what's replacing the
repealed RMA which came as a bit of a
surprise to many in local government
that they're going to repeal that and
having in either case declare what's
going to replace in the short term what
the government or some of the government
ministers have told me is that they will
have a a mechanism for dealing with two
things one is renewable energy and the
other is the Wastewater discharge so I
think we will get some changing
landscape as we go forward past the
initial 100 days and I wonder why given
that that's an un unlevel playing field
at the moment why we are starting to do
a consent process for Clifton 5 years
ahead of
time seems an awfully long lead in
time uh what we be again we've what we
wanted to do was essentially engage a
planning team in particular because we
didn't want to start the process 3 years
out and be told uh you've started too
late um I was particularly aware um when
I was at uh one of the conferences this
year around a council that's at the 10e
point and they still haven't gotten
their consent approved 10 years after
starting the process um it is a
complicated space I absolutely agree
it's changing and we don't know what
that landscape's going to be in the
future we sort of have to play the ball
that we have in front of us at the
moment um what I can say is the planning
team that we have assembled have advised
us to expect this one to be complicated
for Clifton um they are not as concerned
around the bluff consent but they have
warned us to expect Clifton to be
complicated and so I just wanted to
throw a bit of a challenge back to I
guess without being rude um you've said
to us at a previous meeting that if we
go beyond 2029 it's not the end of the
world so if we did take 10 years we
started in 2027 and went 5 years past
the decline given it denon's 20 years
pass so long as we were heading in the
right direction and trying to resolve
the issues we're not going to get held
up by any regulator who says well you're
not complying and so I just I just
wondered about that um and I wondered
about the issue that Tom raised as well
about partnership with Tammy and given
the current environment that we face
which is uh I guess we'll have some
protesters outside the building at 5:00
on this issue why have we added to
baruna into this consenting
debate so early in so early in the piece
5 years out so the first piece that I
speak to just be around that time frame
um for the consent process um as I have
advised through our long-term planning
process around where we have put money
into the long-term plan um the expert
advice that we've received is that we
wouldn't start the detailed design and
construction of plant upgrades for
Clifton until after we had received the
new consent and that we would expect to
work with the Regional Council around
staging of those consent conditions to
allow us to design and construct that
new plant after 2029 rather than having
to do it ahead of time however the
expectation is still that we would need
to start next year to work through that
process the options will be
significant um around and and to be
honest there will be new technology that
we will be unfamiliar with as a council
that we are going to have to work
through in that
process um so just one other quick
question if we get there quicker we can
slow it down yeah um uh you mentioned
several times environment South but it
was my understanding that the regulator
of three orders which includes the
discharge of waste water is actually the
regulator that's been um legislated for
by the previous government and I
understand the current government's not
repealing
that yeah they're not repealing the the
water quality or the regulator so surely
if we're consenting in this area we're
accountable to the regulator uh not to
it's not quite that clear um the tomada
ROI are the I guess the direct regulator
for water quality um they are not the
direct regulator for Waste Water um what
they're essentially their role as I
understand it is to make sure that our
regional councils who already hold that
regulatory role for Wastewater and storm
water uh do the job that they are
required to
so my understanding at this stage and
tomato Roi have been quite clear that
they'll form up their Wastewater role in
the future at the moment their first
focus is around water supply but as I
understand it they will be more
regulating the regulator than regulating
us
directly and the last part of the second
last question I asked you was why two
raka are invited into the process 5
years out when we already have Tammy
there who are like from what what I
understand Tammy um the voices that we
should be going to because we pay for
that organization to give us advice so
the where we've talked about inviting in
the to raka that's uh on the basis of
the bluff um consent that we currently
have underway um we haven't gotten into
a position of forming up the stakeholder
group yet for
Clifton
well but still still for that one where
obviously me unhinge me a little bit why
would we hope I'd be invited into a
bluff con
so we are take essentially taking
guidance from Tammy and what they've
advised us is that they believe that we
should have both um our and why hopai
represented that's quite yep thank you
okay p uh Ty or a definitely has an
interest in both the water supply as
well as um waste water so I I noticed
here that you're looking at uh
commencing a strategic business case do
you have a time frame around what that
would look like uh it depends on which
one you're asking about are you asking
about the alternative water supply yes
aliser are you happy to talk to
the yeah that all depend on proving the
Equus so it'll be July after July next
year okay Y and and I noticed that um
the bluff waste waterer consent actually
expires in December
2025 but then when I went over it was
like really not
considered um by the technical to be a
lower type risk
asset so you know um but then I come
down and it talks about um issues around
high salt concentrated trade
waste could be sort of one of the main
issues so that that that is one of the
challenges that we'll have at that site
yeah so literally it's more than just a
low risk it's actually probably about a
medium to a high when you're talking
about high salt content um I think what
we're when we're comparing it to Clifton
we're talking about it being a lower
risk not a low it's still you know it's
still a complicated site um but it
doesn't come with the complexities that
um a site like Clifton does okay thank
you right look up H sorry liy thank you
Mr Cher um going back to the bluff issue
I notice on page 90 we're looking at
applying for a 35e consent duration as a
stretched Target but with the knowledge
that similar ones have been given a 25e
term so is just just for interest are we
trying to set a precedent here is there
some particular reason for trying for
the 35 years stretch T I'm happy if
alist wants to jump in but essentially
this is something whereby historically
we've had longer consents and there's
now a preference that that is being um
put forward around shorter consent
durations where essentially our stretch
Target would be to convince our
stakeholders to uh allow us to have a
longer term consent every time that we
do this there's a significant investment
by the community in redesigning um the
process and going through the consenting
process so we'd be wanting to give our
stakeholders confidence that they can um
approve a longer term consent for us um
thereby pushing out that next investment
by the
community yeah that's that's correct
it's essentially an asset management
driven decision and providing security
for the community so the longer we can
have a consent for the more security we
can give that that Community or Bluff so
that's the driver for the 35 years but
precedents have set otherwise so it
would set a useful new precedent if we
were to achieve the 35 year stretch
Target correct thank you
EV Mr chair just a
clarification um and as as members of
the table are aware I am a governor at
to Mara I will not be on The Advisory
Group but the difference between our
staff and Runa membership is the
question I think that has um the cour of
M once clarified because uh our staff
are our staff
they are not us um sometimes members of
our e do work for our organization
they're not necessarily who are giving
advice in this instance I think it's you
need to be clear of the difference
between our K Mahi
and um the advice that and support that
they give to councils and our Governors
who are actually
or our um e members who actually might
be sitting at this at this particular
particular invitation group to to
simplify that distinction and please
tell me if I'm overstepping would that
be similar to um Tammy would be like
inviting in Bago city council staff to a
meeting versus inviting the elected
members to me absolutely and appropriate
thank you
Erin Mr May third time just in response
to's
clarification if if if tamy
staff uh and their manager can't give us
advice on a consent for a water
discharge you'd have to beg the question
what do they give us advice
on I mean that's that's not a complex
area surely you'd expect Tammy to give
us advice to consult with the two knas
we required um to give us advice that's
what we're paying for through the Tammy
process but then we add another layer on
again and everyone says that's cheer
that
her star should not be doing that don't
quite get
that so chair I don't think that's quite
what I
said the our staff are planners and and
Technical Support so it's no different
than um uh mugan or U Mr snow or any um
staff person going to a meeting but
taking the chair of the committee
or another interested counselor with
them on a Copa um however if I you know
I can
assure the table that it will not be me
I also can say that because we have an
interest in the water alternative water
supply as opposed to the bluff thing if
they they run side by side we would want
to be part of that but on the Clifton
side that's up to a where they still
want to be a member given that they are
affected by what goes on in the New
River EST out into the sea so that's but
I think that's a matter for another day
I just think you it's been raised it's a
challenge I'm happy to clarify with the
c m any time he wants to speak with me
separately okay look I've got one
question and u a comment I'll start with
a comment first the the clipon one the
consent which is the complex major one
um we really do hope for either great
technology improvements or something
because in the case of it having to go
to land the worst case scenario that 89
million would not be enough that's CU
obviously we've gone from metal Point
haven't we somewhere that could cover
optional bases the one with the arua
water supply now the chatt the chattan
aquaa um what I've read about that is
we're not sure what fills it whether
it's a static body of
water and it may not be replenished
again if we start drawing it out so how
what sort of tests are going to enable
us to find out that it's filled by a
catchment area somewhere and it's not
just a a trapped um you know piece of
the ice age or something yeah firstly
I'm not a
hydrologist please don't Comm commit me
to this and but would they run pumping
tests um so this next round so the
original pumping tests that were done on
it um were to a certain volume and they
took a certain amount out so this next
time we can take more water out faster
uh and then they and then what they do
is they stop pumping and they measure
the recharge rate right of the of the of
the area that they're taking water
out and I'm sure there's lots of
calculations and algorithms and whatever
you they go with that but that's the
principle of it so they actually
measuring the recharge capability
no excellent that was the last document
I read on this had that question mark
over the recharge yeah correct so we're
taking we're actually going to find out
that right so any further comments
questions we've got
um the recommendations we've got four
recommendations there who would like to
move that thanks Lesley second to Tom
I'm going to put those four
recommendations all those in favor I I
against they are carry thank you Alis
thank
you right activities
report um you want to take that error or
we going to absolutely I'm happy to
speak to
that uh there's three key pieces that
I'd like to draw your attention to with
the activity report um the first is that
I provided an update on the requirement
for us to pull forward um the resaling
of the surface on Queen's Drive um we
went to W katah with a request to
provide additional funding to us for
this year's reseal program um by doing
that what we did what we didn't want to
have to do was reprioritize other sites
that we were planning to resal this year
and divert money to that Queen Drive
site and hold other sites for longer um
we've been lucky in that I think we're
being at the end of the long-term plan
cycle there must be money that other
organizations haven't spent and wahi
have approved us to have additional
funding to allow us to do that Queen
Drive site without having to
reprioritize funds from the rest of our
resales program so that's a good outcome
for us for this
year um did you want me to go through
all of them or take questions on each
one I think we'll just take questions
and yeah um Mr M um so how does this re
this resaling fit with the police
inquiry and the coroners court that
looked into those the accident which had
a question mark over the ceiling now
I've
heard sort of informally that the police
don't believe it was a service are we in
a position to determine that so that
this has not seen to be sort of a little
bit of guilt by stealth as it were um so
I think I'd advised a previous piece of
advice to council which was that there
had been testing of the road Surface
after the accident um happened um that
didn't give us any cause for concern at
stage um when however that wasn't done
with the scrim truck that comes through
every couple of years um when the scrim
trucks come through now it's now saying
we've now tipped past that point of
where we should intervene um in a reseal
situation so following question for that
obviously is that that um more careful
assessment does that predate back to the
time of the
accident the the scrim truck assessment
no that's only just been done this year
yeah so it's done this year but when was
the excident previous year previous last
year so is it reasonable to assume that
somebody might draw the conclusion that
the road service contributed we didn't
have the what we had in terms of
Technology within New Zealand at the
time gave us um no reason to think that
the road surface had contributed what I
can't tell you though is that if we'd
have had the international technology
whether that would have given us a
different answer we don't believe so um
but we also filter all of our
information provide all of our
information back to the police to Aid in
their investigation okay thank you R um
thanks Erin just may ask some of the
questions I was interested in but just
with the um a couple when will this um
resurface take effect and uh the product
that we've got currently um along that
stretch of concern I've noticed in some
areas that there's been what i' call
the products combusted um it's become
loose in areas so I'm wondering also
what product will we put back on there
in the resell and would it be better to
last longer than what this recent one
has yes uh absolutely really good
question um it was something that the
team tussled with because if we just
went through and did another chip seal
resurface we were concerned around its
ability to bond to the existing surface
um that's why it has been the decision
to go for an ashev um resurfacing that
will eliminate that concern around
bonding and also provide a longer term
surface that's great
news um anything else on that one before
I move on to the other we got Grant and
then Barry yeah um I'm wondering whether
this a failure of the performance on the
contract cuz when that road was laid it
was laid on a really really hot day and
ever since there's been issues with that
road and so I'm interested in how we'd
monitor that contract in terms of should
it have failed at this stage or was it a
FLW in the actual when it was actually
resealed y so those are discussions that
have been had um on multiple occasions
with the contractor um that were there's
been work done at the contractor's cost
um to date um around trying to improve
that surface um and obviously the you
know that that um hasn't held the life
of the asset to where it should have
it's still failed um a few years early
um so those are absolutely the
conversations that we are having with
the contractor um and something that I
would brief counseling and on in public
excluded if I
wished okay right Barry yeah this is in
relation this isn't is isn't in relation
to Queens Park I'm thinking more of uh
clud Street around Bluff Road where all
the heavy
traffic goes it seems to be a continuing
putting a patch on a
patch the have we never ever thought
about concreting that part Stateway yeah
I was going to say it depends which
piece you're speaking to if you're
actually around on the state highway P
you go off Bond Street on uh the heavy
traffic bypass and go on to clud Street
turn round and then go on to Bluff
Road are you talking about before you
enter onto Bluff Road yeah um so then if
if it's sitting within our Network
that's what it's something I can raise
with the team one of the things though
is that
um we're funded by um wahi around a
essentially a a hierarchy of roads and
we are expected that some of our roads
should always be deteriorating over time
none of our roads should be in in
perfect condition otherwise we're we're
over investing in them um what we do is
we um put forward a a bid for budgets to
reseal our roads each year um and we
very good at spending that budget each
year but we have to prioritize which
roads we are holding and which roads we
are actually able to resal with the
budgets that we have available it's just
it's just the amount of tonnage that
goes on like all the logging trucks yeah
everything goes on that one stretch Road
and it's continually breaking down all
yeah and and it's one of those pieces
that we've constantly got to do that
assessment around um value for money of
repair versus um upgrade yeah just just
thinking about the Gold Coast and that
they conquered the roads and they don't
have trouble with them at a very high
expense yeah probably but what the
expense of replacing it at all time
putting a patch on a patch okay Alan um
this is weit unrelated to but I just
want to ask here with the current
government's um plan to um stop reducing
speeds um bear in mind that when we uh
introduce that at the council here a
couple of years ago it's going to take a
couple of years to do it um are we
looking at stopping reducing speeds in
in our
area and you know on the in line with
what the government now is saying
they're going to
do um we we finished the prog we are
where we are and is there any plan to
perhaps review some of the changes that
have been currently made like you know
in's Road
um so what I'd say is that we'll
obviously continue to monitor what's
happening nationally and what the
guidance is to us um however the speed
Reduction Program that Council went
ahead with I would suggest compared to a
lot of communities was quite
conservative um what inago city had done
in that space um we were then
essentially waiting to see um what
direction um central government policy
took moving forward I wouldn't expect at
this stage that we would look to revisit
any of those unless we were getting
Community feedback to do so regardless
of what's happening with central
government policy um but at this stage
we'll just be being Guided by what
central government comes out with we had
no plans to be going and doing extreme
um speed reduction programs um across
the city at this stage
regardless well it's a different subject
so if Evelyn's want to talk about spe
then take her
first well
spotted uh you through you through you
Mr Cher to eron
or whoever wants to volunteer
um where are we in
monitoring the impact positive or
negative of the speed reductions we've
made because I think
whilst um central government govern may
change their position on these things
we're working on behalf of our communi
so if we have statistics to say it's
been
beneficial or it hasn't been beneficial
isn't that what should form our opinion
rather than
um something else and and so where are
we collecting those statistics when do
we start seeing the reports that come
from that and how many years do we have
to give it before we actually can see a
statistical Trend do you think um I need
to check with the team exactly what
they've got around the program um but
I'd expect that we'd be looking at at
least 18 months of bedding in because
obviously there's a period of change for
people to adapt to and get used to a new
normal um and then we would start doing
that that consultation piece we also
monitor obviously we get our request for
service system where people who aren't
happy with various different things
would be feeding that back in
um there are still a couple of spots
that we're hearing a few grumbles about
um that we're just continuing to monitor
but in general um we haven't had a great
deal of negative feedback around the
reduction program that we've implemented
at this stage so if I may do a followup
is the feedback that we're getting
positive or negative or both uh both um
so particularly um around the as I
understand it around the lower speeds in
the um sort of community Hub centers
that's been quite positive um I do
believe that areas like C road is still
getting some rumbles about
it thank you how many don't come from
Alan I declin to
answer thanks um this is a completely
different subject here and I'll probably
be accused to being small-minded by
raising this BFF I look at the domestic
battery disposal page in the last page
of that um which is a page three of that
report this say staff have organized a
blessing event to Mark the launch of the
program um we do we need to organize a
blessing event for a butter recycling
program um so just before we get into
those questions I just wanted the
opportunity to talk to those next items
because we'd only been taking questions
on the Queens Drive one at the moment so
if I can just give a quick overview that
and then hopefully that might deal with
some of those questions um the first
piece has just been around obviously
drawing your attention to the waset
mascot um a piece of work that the team
have been doing around trying to engage
with the community around that product
standardization um there's been
significant push both from this Council
as well as all of the waset councils
around how are we engaging with our
community to try to get people thinking
about doing the right thing um and bits
McGee as he's now been DED um is part of
that program of trying to engage the
community around making sure that we are
not only doing the right thing from an
environmental perspective but also doing
the right thing from a cost perspective
because whenever we get um things wrong
in our waste Journey um that contributes
to those those higher costs and those
higher rates the better that we can be
in that space um the more efficient we
can be from a cost perspective um no
birdie
Budgy around the battery Disposal system
this is a really interesting one and I
think councilor pottinger may have some
comments on this we've been receiving
significant push from our contractors
around battery disposal for quite some
time um it's been contributing to fires
both at our recycle processing facility
as well as at at our landfill um and we
you know we've been definitely being
read the riot act by our contractors in
in that respect unfortunately and and I
think there's a lack of awareness of
this that you know I I had to change the
um button remote um for my car the other
day and I took the button remote out and
I went gee what do I do with that now
and I think most people would just put
it in the bin and contribute to that
problem not actually aware of the fact
that they aren't allowed to put that
into their rubbish been take it to the
transfer station or take it to the
landfill so there's a big education
component that we need to do with the
community but we weren't able to do that
because we couldn't actually tell the
community G whiz where can you take that
um so this is actually something that
part part of the reason for wanting to
do the blessing was that media
opportunity actually to draw attention
to the fact that disposing of your
lithium batteries your batteries out of
your mobile phone Etc is not something
that you can just do into your been and
most people a lot of people don't
actually realize that so that's part of
what we want to draw attention to
through this process I know that really
should be the function of a blessing
though should it to draw to draw public
attention and some kind of adverti I
mean I can see the sense obviously of a
blessing to open a bridge or even a
museum or a Causeway or something but a
battery
recycling project I mean to me that's
actually a misuse yeah of the the nature
blessing I think what I'd say is that
the there was an INT to do a bit of a
media photo
opportunity both the team involved um on
the um on the team side as well as on
the contractor side were Keen to go
ahead and and do a blessing so I don't
see a reason um if we have somebody
available to do that why we would stop
them from doing that yeah but it's not a
completely free thing quite apart for
any issues around you know it's a nature
of blessing but it's not a completely
Ely free thing it involves staff taking
time off to go to it involves no you
know counselors will get invited to go
to it um presumably Evelyn or somebody
will go and give the blessing I mean
there's a fair Fairly significant
commitment of time involved in it and I
I just think the fact it gets you some
free publicity I don't think it's good
enough reason for a blessing but
personal view so I guess what I'd say is
I would raise the point that and I've
discussed this um with the chief
executive we don't have a coordinated
process at the moment for events of this
type um and I have suggested whether or
not there is a standardized approach to
this rather than a team by te um
Approach at the moment maybe something
that Council wants to consider at the
moment it is left as a team by team
approach Grant yeah I'm I'm pretty
disappointed actually um you know mascot
gets designed and there's no cheese roll
on
it there's no you want a recycled cheese
roll excuse me you don't throw
cheese just pointed out you know given
the quality of cheese rolls that we make
down here I can see why probably they
don't end up in the
waste I'll apologize to to that as an
Australian I would say perhaps to the um
Wast net elected members that you you
expressed your disappointment that they
didn't feed that back to us you could do
that uh I've got
Ria I I wait into this discussion a bit
hesitantly um coming from Tom's point of
view about blessings for the sake of
blessings for media coverage for me
personally I don't feel comfortable with
that it might be the new modern way that
things are done I don't yeah I don't
feel comfortable I kind of feel that and
I don't mean it to be strong if you take
this the wrong
way it's not that I know teer to blast
patries or the disposal off batteries
but then I can understand if it's going
into the Earth there's something there
that can um damage her and I understand
that side but to say that we're just
going to do a Lessing to get a bit of
media coverage on this I think that's
probably just the way i' to clarify that
I wasn't saying we were doing it for
media coverage what I was saying is we
were organizing a vent an event to do
for media coverage and then it was
decided to also add a blessing on to
that as well okay so we were already
having that that staff time there
regardless
okay Barry as part of the wa waste net
um Team I uh I wrote a email this
morning and this is the following I am
strugg struggling to understand why
we're having a blessing to bless this
site considering it's a scrap mle yard
it's the old palas SC it doesn't make
any sense to me we do going to be doing
this for everything or
Peter yes when I read the agenda last
night last night about having a blessing
for a dead
battery what the hell's a bloody world
coming to you know where's going to stop
it's unbelievable you do it for a pet uh
but not a dead battery no look I think
people look I'm going to I've been
invited to the opening of this facility
which is essential um and thank God for
it it's it's it's there now we can
everything from vaping things to
computer batteries which are really
dangerous now the fact that there's a
blessing there or not it's the opening
of this new facility which is of high
value to this city so look I'm I'm I'm
openminded to it's like someone saying a
couple of speeches and and it's all part
of what's happening so as cheer um and
both on Wast like I'm pleased and
whatever happens
there um I think it's going to be great
and I think the media coverage hopefully
will get people to think about their
about their batteries can I just say
thank you to the chair for saying that
because the staff have worked incredibly
hard on this they were really excited
about it our contractors are really
excited about it and unfortunately so
far the feedback has not been
particularly positive to the team in
that
space Sorry p in response to you CH I
totally agree it it's like it's a place
it's a new pathway it's going to be a
new piece of
um you know things happening for our
batteries yes disposal within Bond
Street and and it's more than just media
coverage it is the opening and the
closing of an
event right Lesley I make you the last
one Lesley oh
okay sorry Evelyn I can't see you down
there I I know I'm very small Mr J um
and I'm right in the
corner as person whose name was
mentioned I haven't been asked to do the
blessing but I do blessings for lots of
things as a deacon um as much as
anything it is about the people who will
work in that
place and if if if it were me I would be
thinking about the people and their
safety and their well-being as I perform
the blessing I think
that sometimes people go to work at a
place and don't know what has happened
there before or they may have a bad
feeling about a place it doesn't matter
but as PA said it's a new beginning and
it is one way of celebrating a new
beginning and clearing the way for what
is to follow um I'd like to applaud the
staff who thought about all of this
because this was not imposed upon them
this is a choice that they are making
for a place in which they are going to
work and um this to me is an indicator
of
how our kahi are looking at the world in
which they live and how they want it to
be and I want to celebrate and applaud
them
it doesn't matter if it's who it is that
does the blessing I think the fact that
they they feel the need for that as part
of um perhaps what we might want to look
at is their health and safety um not as
I certainly would not ever participate
myself as part of a media event as such
but inevitably such events to attract
media so it's a little bit of the you
know um a two-sided coin but thank you
um for all those who made this
particular initiative possible because
I'm with Miss Moran what do I do with my
batteries now I know thank
you okay the last
is and we're going to end this it's
amazing no one's talked about Age Care
and uh we haven't got the yet yeah we're
going to go to activities aren we yeah
we're still in activities
lesle thanks Mr G I am prompted to add
my voice to the positive congratulations
for this event I actually read the um
same document that other counselors read
last night and thought great positive
um upm Market way to launch a new
program and a new mascot good on them
for thinking outside the square and
using a bit of initiative um I would
like to congratulate staff on actually
thinking that way
and as Evelyn said thinking about staff
um health and safety and the positive
use and the difference this is going to
make to a lot of people in their
Community who have for a long time
thought about what they do with
batteries and what we know about the
fires that have been caused at our sites
and so forth I just saw this as a
positive initiative congratulations to
the staff for actually taking the
initiative to think about having a
positive event that is going to create
interest and attention and get the
message through on an important part of
recycling I think that's the last
comment thank you on the
battery Saga not on the batter you're
not talking about the batteries I want
to talk about the batteries okay right
just a quick question for the two
delegates that sit on waset some time
ago I put two reports to the Wast net
chair on the incinerator issue potential
for incinerators as posted to landfill
have they been tabled are you aware of
that um I wasn't at the last uh no it be
before the last one October 16 yeah
prior of that it would
be well that I just wanted to reflect
that's really frustrating I did a lot of
work post pan and also with the wi power
wi power Council that's now considering
a consent from a private sector investor
to have a incinerator and there also
work being done in Denmark and and I
would have thought you know that when
we're trying to think about ways not to
contaminate our land and it doesn't
matter where we put stuff at the moment
where a line's a great place and it is
at some later stage we will probably
regret putting stuff under land um for
that not to be tabled is just I think um
frustrating I think I mean I can either
raise it or you can raise it with the
chair of w now oh look I've written to
him twice I mean okay we've got a
meeting
I mean you do the work in the background
yep
okay Grant um just on 95 Ball books the
f
um sort of key notes those errors
happening in those some of those key
infrastructure pieces that were
identified in the long-term plan or you
mean blockages and repairs yeah Etc um I
couldn't tell you the detail of those
particular
ones but um any of those areas where we
are having regular blockages or regular
breaks is all what informs into that
program for anual so likely they are
yeah yeah okay and then secondly on page
96 just looking at
that those
notes it' be good to see that turned
into a performance report so you know
what is 345 km of sweeping man is that
against 1,000 km should have been done
or is it you know um 29 bus shelters
cleaned as opposed to you know cly we
meant to be cleaning 50 so it'll be good
to see that information turned into
something that we can get some insights
into this is how we're performing in our
roading Network and some of those other
pie against their sort of set objectives
yeah I I think it's a it's a work in
progress for us um in terms of it was
information that we weren't necessarily
holding and pulling through 12 months
ago um the team are now starting to
collate that data um but to be honest
that we don't have in place yet good
systems to make that simple for the
teams to be able to um give us really
good reporting around how our networks
are performing um so it is a bit of a a
journey for us to keep I agree we need
to keep building on it um but we're
probably not going to get to where I'd
like to get to or where I expect a lot
of counsil would like to get to as
quickly um as we'd like to but we would
have budget Ed um likes of grading will
have a budget for grading budget for
sweeping budget for cleaning so you know
how we're performing against those
things so you're just asking for we we
can give you against totals that's fine
what's the mix of service and cost I'm
looking for
probably okay any further questions on
the activity report um look I've got a a
um a comment to make but uh without Mr
Pearson being here it's about the urban
mowing and earlier this month I raised
an issue about the quality of the Cent
median strips and one of them was down
we Mr llo lips and uh in the end of
Queen's drive and and the middle of the
grass was mowed and everything near its
um concrete curbs was this high and and
look it looks it looks terrible so I one
of the staff members rang me back and
said no it's not good enough um and it's
being looked into but I'm not sure where
we are and I think there's been enough
emails going around too about people
addressing the mowing of of Lawns and
the grass flowing there so I think is it
possible here in that next
infrastructure meeting it do it to be
you know that that mowing thing may come
back because it shows we've seen photos
of it looks like hay you know on you
know it's been left sorry which street
was it oh no this is all the center
plots in town and and Russell assured me
that that if you if the mo can't get to
it it needs to be sprayed well it's a
green that's right yeah yeah you know
around there um so I think I may have
spoken at a a committee meeting
previously um there there is a little
bit of
um pieces here that some's done through
our maintenance contractor some's done
through our internal team um definitely
um we're trying to raise the standard on
both but particularly around our
maintenance contract um we're in the
initial months of that new contract with
fon Hogan um one of the areas that we've
really asked that team to focus on and
to up skill on is around essentially
pride in our city and what our city
particularly in those high-profile areas
looks like both from a a mowing capacity
rubbish in our Center plots what our
Gardens look like our streets sweeping
things like that so it's something that
we are aware we're not where we want to
be at the moment and it's an absolute
Focus for both sides of the team but it
is going going to be a little bit of a
work in progress because I think we have
gotten a little bit used to what we're
used to and we need to break that cycle
moving forward I think what makes it
worse is that we're in Spring and
everything is growing everyone will know
their own Lawns I'm I'm cutting mine
twice a week and and it's yeah I mean
but it's that period you've got to watch
it Council staff cutting you la no it's
not Council staff the golf
course it's absolutely a priority for us
as well that's called a divot
right so uh Peter you've got a comment
yeah talking of grass um I've noticed
that uh Thompson's buh it hasn't been
mowed for two months it's it's very very
long I think that's going to come back
in Erin when uh I would be speaking that
one that'll be through
your when yesterday or the day before
last week it had been moded months
before that so what we have that be a
reserve issue we got reserves there we
have them as well I think um
between now and the next infrastructure
mining reserves comes under Mr C you
want me to
move yeah okay so you've moved and
seconded that the report we received put
that all those in
favor against carried right we might
next uh activities report we might have
a blessing for that to uh to give us
help
to that's not funny do it in
the right okay we are now going to move
into public excluded uh for the reasons
mentioned in the agenda can I have
someone please move that moved Evelyn
seconded Barry put that all those in
favor against that is carried thank you
that's the end of
streaming